okay so recently riot games was accused
of basing their newest league of legends
character
seraphine off of a real life woman
without her consent
we're talking hair facial features
hobbies
the whole deal and what's craziest is
this isn't even the first time they've
been accused of this
[Music]
all right guys we're on the road to 2
million subscribers
i want you to pause the video hit pause
scroll down and hit that subscribe
button
let's hit this milestone together now on
november 12th a twitter user named
stepney
posted a twitter thread and a much
longer medium article titled
the problem with seraphi it turns out
the problem
was that she thinks seraphine is her
in the article she makes the claim that
riot's newest champion
is based off of her and her life the
author whose real name is stephanie
claims that she had a relationship with
an anonymous riot games employee back in
2019
and that relationship in conjunction
with a list of alleged similarities
between seraphine
and her has her feeling pretty
uncomfortable so how we're going to
start this story
is by talking about all of the things
she says are similar between her
and syrah first is the obvious one
stephanie and seraphine
look pretty similar they're both young
women have very similar hair colors
similar glasses and share similar facial
features alright if i stopped here you
might say to yourself
well they look similar but what's the
big deal here's where her allegations
get a little stronger
with the release of seraphine riot games
has rolled out a
pretty extensive social media campaign
complete with a twitter account that
personifies the character and it's on
those pages where a lot of the photos
comparing
seraphine and stephanie the way they
look the way they pose
have come from stephanie and seraphine
both draw as a hobby
and stephanie even says that seraphine's
drawings look like hers
riot also announced on twitter that
seraphine was joining their virtual pop
group
kda on stephanie's birthday and lastly
we have what i think might be the
strongest part of her allegations
screenshots from the relationship she
had with that riot employee back in
2019.
in the medium article she includes a
screenshot from text messaging
conversations with that person
who she refers to as john where he
suggests
making a re skin based off of her and
then
as she's discussing those messages she
also refers to another time
where he suggested she fly to los
angeles to do voice acting
for a top secret project so all things
considered there's a lot going into her
claim here
not just the fact that they look similar
now one piece of evidence to the
contrary of stephanie's claims is that
given cedan a senior game designer at
riot
posted a tweet on october 29th saying
that seraphine was
actually based off of riot whiskies and
then on november 12th
riot games officially responded to her
claims they sent a statement to tim
rizzo a reporter for inven global
denying that seraphine was based off
stephanie
here's what it says quote seraphine was
independently created by riot games and
was not based on any individual
including mysteries additionally the
former employee ms doris is referring to
left riot more than a year ago and was
in a department and role that has no
input whatsoever into the creative
design process
we take all claims of misappropriation
seriously and immediately investigated
miss doris's allegations
after receiving a legal demand letter
from her attorney last month
we confirmed that her claim of being the
basis for seraphine lacks merit
communicated this to her attorney and
invited him to further discuss the facts
with us
we are still waiting for our response
end quote now the majority of this
is exactly what you'd expect from this
kind of statement but it's important not
to gloss over the fact that ryan says
that they
did receive a legal demand letter from
stephanie's lawyer
and that's where this story gets a
little more interesting because this is
not the first time that riot games have
been accused of this
it's not even the second time now the
first of those two additional
accusations
was made on twitter and nothing really
came with it but the second
was actually settled in court on august
14th
2017 it was made public that riot games
lost a lawsuit to former soccer player
edgar davids
due to his resemblance to the striker
lucian skin
in that case the judge ruled that riot
games would have to reveal
how much money they made off of the
striker lucian skin
and then allow auditors to decide how
much money davids would get
now since stephanie's lawyer did send a
letter to ryan
and with the precedent of the striker
lucian situation
i decided to speak to a lawyer myself to
get some perspective
on the legal side of the story josh
marcus an esports lawyer from here in
toronto
sat down with me to shed some of his
light on the situation
now before i get into that it's
important to note that this
isn't actual legal advice it's just his
opinion
as a lawyer he told me that when the
news dropped he was definitely
interested in how it played it
when i asked him if stephanie would have
a case he mostly just said it depends on
a lot of factors
broadly speaking when you're a celebrity
you're going to
value exposure when you're a
non-celebrity you're going to value
privacy
right and that is just a broad assertion
that of course is going to apply always
but what ports are looking at it is you
know if you are michael jordan you have
more of a an interest in gaining
exposure
but b you have more of a commercial
interest that you have to protect
he did say that when it comes to a
situation like stephanie's
her argument gets a lot stronger with
every hyper
personalized piece of evidence that she
has it's one thing for someone to look
like the character
but if they share personality type
hobbies
distinguishing characteristics like
tattoos then
that becomes a lot stronger argument if
it was just
another redhead with glasses right you
might end up
on one end of that spectrum and if you
go into
i believe in that thread you know
there's they talk about kind of
the lore behind the character and you
know the stories that come along with it
if that is genuinely based on this
person's life
story or life experiences such that she
could be identified from it
you're on the other end of that spectrum
another point that i thought was
interesting when we're talking about
this situation
that josh brought up is the level of
fame of the person making these
accusations
when it comes to situations like this
it's a lot easier for someone who's
famous to claim damages for using their
likeness
because everybody knows what they look
like but the flip side of that
is you know the creative process where
you're basing
characters or any traits off of a
generic type of person
it's a little more complicated because
again you're not talking about gwen
stefani and no doubt here where there is
a very clear benefit to using that
likeness
here it's you know yeah they have red
hair they wear glasses
you know maybe some of the lore is based
off of their character
but there's no you know the average joe
who doesn't know stephanie
doesn't care about that right they are
not choosing to play as his character
because
it is based off death now before i ended
my conversation with josh
i asked him about that former soccer
player edgar davids and whether or not
a case like this having precedent would
have any impact on
potential legal proceedings assuming
they didn't settle and it was actually
found in his favor
um right so a court has ruled that yes
you violated his rights by doing this
and you have some presidential value
there and you can point to that pattern
of behavior that hey riot has
a history of basing their characters off
of real people
so the fact that this woman who dated
you know the artist or whoever was who
came up with it
is making this claim really isn't that
outlandish right it's not
so crazy to imagine because hey they've
done it before
now it's important to note that we don't
know yet if this case will
ever end up in a courtroom stephanie and
her lawyer
have only sent a legal letter to ryan
games but i figured given the nature of
the situation
some extra legal perspective might be
helpful this situation is strange
complicated and it's made a lot of
headlines since it first popped up on
twitter and i mean
it's esports twitter everybody loves to
[ __ ] on game developers but this
situation is unique and murky in a way
that we
don't see as often especially because
despite what you may have seen on reddit
the situation is not as simple as
stephanie saying that seraphine just
looks like her
it kinda looks like you're trying to
figure out the the gender of your child
but you know
yeah yeah you could go full gender
reveal
yeah oh there you go okay that's cool
you can sync it to your music it's just
great that's [ __ ] sick
uh you know you just go off in here have
a party
you know it's quarantined man you gotta
you gotta entertain yourself somehow
one of the weirdest things is uh you can
sync them to just audio like just like
whatever your desktop audio is
so if you were raging i could sync the
lights to your range
oh so they would like it would uh flash
brightly
freak out
i like that i need me some lights for
that exact reason dude they're [ __ ] man
it's fun
yeah all right gamer lights man that's
the future